what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
trailer for a movie but directed by a
guy who when asked on our live stream
recently one of the questions was who
are your five favorite directors John
specifically directed at him and one of
people he listed was Robert Rodriguez
Bobby rods he listed all the Sharkboy
and Lava Girl movies Spy Kids films but
he has not seen films like Desperado or
machete but you see machete Hills so
we're here to do this at stars Ben
Affleck has had a fantastic reception at
uh South by Southwest right this was
called the airline yes Southwest
Airlines every flight every time those
those letters I think it's s m that's
what my memory tells me or it sounds
like a radio station they should change
it you should change that you're
listening to SS class W but it had a
fantastic reception and it wasn't even
finished yet that's how confident they
are in this I like the idea of pairing
Ben Affleck and Robert Rodriguez
something about that just sounds really
cool to me leave a like this is going to
be a very Zen reaction uh let's get to
it
[Music]
face off hello
[Applause]
oh
I think I'm ready for Duty do you feel
ready I think Sam isn't keep me safe
personal
giving back my daughter is this crime
currently in progress today
you see that guy on the bench William
victory
it's very hot today it's like a sinus
another scorcher is got an evil scarf
whoa what
what is going on
[Music]
but I'm the wrong man
where is she oh this is like a
supernatural movie
or sci-fi or both guys
the hell are you what makes total
strangers pull off an elaborate bank
heist are you familiar with the concept
of hypnotics hypnotics they're using
hypnosis to rob banks yes to influence
the brain so
do not excuse them to make you see a
version of the world
doesn't exist
that's his daughter yes in the future
but now it's not him anymore next stop
I have to know everything
Dominos by my daughter
[Music]
you know what you're dealing with
whoa
what you see it's like Tomorrow Never
Dies
the hell of his little bond in there
everything that you see and do
[Music]
all right
so The Reflex
whoa that was surprising I expected just
a Cheesy action movie
because it's Robert don't assault my boy
he can get serious once I'd like a lot
of his From Dusk Till Dawn is one of my
all-time favorite movies and I do want
an Elita sequel I was surprised by that
it was doing all these typical tropes
especially like oh I didn't see my
daughter and he's working the case
because you know he's too high for this
job like yeah it's got some of that uh
Noir detective inspirational touches
because there's this trailer in a lot of
its own ways is is like a fun hypnotic
trailer it didn't feel like incredibly
mind-bending but just enough mind
bending to latch onto its premise and so
I liked a lot of what we saw here
because I feel like it can escalate into
something that gets very trippy and very
weird I really wanted to commit
intensely to its subject there's an ALT
Universe where Nicholas Cage is starring
in this movie oh that's a great call
absolutely he is yes yes because this is
also face off this also reminds we have
other Ben Affleck movies from back in
the day like oh yeah yes yes yes oh and
there are probably a couple more his
names elude me now but yeah that Ben
Affleck on the run from sci-fi's shadowy
organization yeah yeah and William
fichner reprising his role from that
Nicholas Cage drive angry yeah there you
go but it kind of reminds me of here his
performance seems like it's plucked
right out of there in a lot of ways yeah
it's some silly ass concept but it's
taking itself really serious which I was
surprised by because that's the one part
of it is this is getting such good
feedback this is getting incredible
feedback I love to hear it the concept
is so kind of silly to me that I feel
like there has to be some sense of
self-awareness but that's kind of a
common thing with Rob Rodriguez trailers
I noticed a lot of the times they the
the trailers will give you something so
serious and then the movies end up
having an awareness of fun that the
trailers don't usually communicate I
don't know if that's the idea I've heard
this is like you know part of the
security of Robert
and so I'm excited to see it imagine
there's some good action oh sure that's
very stylish I was surprised with Alice
Braga who looks like she's going to be a
prominent character normally in a
Rodriguez film I expect them to be a
little bit more badass in the trailers
because I think he does a great job at
bringing female heroin addicts to life I
guess really portraying the struggles in
play with the immense compassion John I
imagine this is your favorite trailer
you've seen the best trailer I've ever
seen
Robert Rodriguez can do no wrong and if
you bring receipts I will just not
acknowledge them no I think the part of
the charm of Robert Rodriguez is that he
has a unique blend of an eye for both
things that are marketable and like the
part of this feels like a bunch of
trailers I've seen and it feels very
much like okay a thriller detective
appealing star slightly trippy and hard
to understand from the trailer concept
but that pulls you in but then once you
get there once you're actually watching
the movie like you said there's probably
a greater sense of actual personality
quirkiness Etc to the proceeding I feel
like Robert Rodriguez has been in the
business long enough to know how to like
pitch something with just enough
marketable bits and then be able to
bring it you know with his own unique
voice about it and I get that sense from
this I mean if you didn't tell me
Rodriguez directed this I wouldn't have
guessed it not the bat at all yeah and
and it's got like a sort of a more
restrained sort of visual style and it
is kind of reminding you of a bunch of
other movies and stuff like that but I
always appreciate one of my conception
like Inception like a number of bonds
even missions impossible to some degree
any any movie really where someone's
like in a semi-exotic location evading
people on a bike
uh you know weaving through the city
just the genre unto itself
um but yeah yeah like I I I love the
excitement of the mystery this is my
kind of Mystery Box where it's like it's
up to you now to make whatever this
concept is this idea that you know these
subtle suggestions these ways that
people have hypnotized you or then going
to like lead to these subconscious
actions like it's it's that thing of
like you read about you know the idea of
hypnosis and you're like I've got a cool
action for that
um and needs like cool twists and turns
I think this is one of those movies that
would need like a convoluted amount of
twists it needs to be so just compact to
the point where you're like you gotta I
feel like you gotta Teeter the line with
too many twists like you gotta be right
at the edge of you're doing too many but
don't quite go there yeah yeah yeah
because that's how you offset the things
that are very familiar about what this
is you know yeah you know Detective guy
with his estranged daughter or daughter
he doesn't spend enough time with and I
feel like Alice Braga probably in some
weird way I don't know if it's that kind
of sci-fi movie but who knows she's
probably his daughter or something weird
Limitless Vibes as well Limitless that's
a good one
um yeah there's there's a whole bunch of
familiar movies in here but I'm excited
to see Rodriguez try out a different
type of Direction style like in terms of
cinematography especially this doesn't
look like a lot of his films yeah this
doesn't look like it was made at his
Warehouse in Texas it doesn't look like
he did everything by himself which you
know I'm always there for but yeah like
especially these days as he does kind of
have to do more sort of slightly mature
filmmakery things I feel like yeah it's
good to delegate a little bit and to
bring your cruise
maybe that's what happened when he
worked on book of Boba Fett was this is
what it's like working with other people
this is not bad I can get used to this
yeah just gotta focus on
overall uh I was pleasantly surprised by
a lot it was here but guys were you
hypnotized by this trailer leave your
thoughts down below
will this lead to them restoring the
Snyder verse wrong with Rob Rodriguez at
the helm we're not letting it go
guys subscribe leave a like
which I think we're stupid
every pixel might Baker you just sound
like a character from Robert Rodriguez
movie or like you know the the banner he
would call his like CG in-house
animation firm that does all of his
movies that he does himself and I feel
like you have that level of Independence
and proactivity pixel Mike Baker comma
Everett you have a boundless creativity
but a childlike spirit and that's what
keeps you fresh after all these years of
subscribing to the patreon and uh you
are not a troublemaker you are a double
r r for realist of the real and at
another R cause you're a reject but in a
good way and uh I would love to be
hypnotized by you I genuinely don't know
what you're saying you know you don't
have to man you're Desperado no idea
a lot of time in Mexico there were some
Spy Kids let me tell you
and every pixel my Baker was one of them
and he saved our butts in 3D because we
can be heroes all right so uh hold on to
your shorts and once well I did Once
Upon a Time in Mexico Sin City all right
that's enough Robert Rodriguez movies
name a couple more in the comments
Everett
thank you